in the year 1956 The Cutting Edge IBM
350 could store about 3.5 megabytes of
data or one photo from your iPhone but
today you can fit about 200 000 photos
on a terabyte the size of your thumbnail
now multiply that by 1000 to get a
petabyte which takes up about one slot
on a server rack get yourself a thousand
of these and now you have one exabyte
about the size of a small data center a
thousand of those and now we're talking
about zettabytes all human activity
generates about one of these every three
days multiply that by a thousand to get
a yata bite which is big enough to store
all the information ever produced by
human since the dawn of man